(Upbeat music)
- I wouldn't say it's
a bike for lazy people,
which a lot of people think,
when they think electric cycles.
So it's more like, an action bike.
(upbeat music)
(Adventurous Upbeat music)
( High intensity rock music)
- [Ali] Something between a
motorcycle and a normal cycle.
- You can control the electric power,
so you choose how much you wanna use it,
but the actual trial is
really, really tiring.
It gives you a good workout.
- It was just a hobby, really,
at the time it was an idea,
a concept, you know, let
me build my own bike.
And, I think it was
about three months later,
I did have my own bike. It
was my own mountain bike--
- [Saqud] Frankenstein.
- Yes, definitely looked
like a Frankenstein bike
and you had batteries
everywhere, wires everywhere,
it was faster but it was
just too scary to ride.
Because it was just too light.
(upbeat music)
We thought, “Okay, well at
least the concept was there.”
- [Saqud] And then we're like,
“This could be a viable business and,
“you know, electric bike was something
that was growing in the,
“around the world.”
- We have to design a
bike which was more for
the U.A.E. market, which is
something you can take out
and actually use on the dunes.
- Saluki, is a local dog breed,
which is very skinny, it's
very fast and it's quiet.
It's a desert dog so it
really fits within our brand
and that's why we picked it.
- The fat bikes are made
for the desert, mainly,
and they can go up to 45
km per hour in the desert,
quietly, without disturbing any wildlife,
without creating any issues in the desert.
And it's a really seamless drive.
- [Fahad] I mean, that was
one of the amazing things,
when riding on the bike. The first time,
you know, desert foxes, I saw desert rabbits,
I saw bugs, I saw lizards,
things I never saw riding
my quad around in the back
of the desert, before.
And it's just, in silence,
it's you and the wind.
It was phenomenal, just
riding on the ridges
of the sand dunes. And
then, the sun goes down,
it's just amazing.
- [Ali] You've gotta try it. I mean,
one thing that we've
noticed, anyone that gets on
these bikes, they come
back with a big smile.
(Dramatic music)